dass ich mit 16 jahren als schülerin von
seinem geschäftsführer so dreckig fertig
gemacht werde
weil ich ein kopftuch trage ich keine
ahnung ich kann mir nicht vorstellen so
wie man so rassist zu stecken das video
der 16 jährigen hamburgerin miriam wurde
innerhalb kürzester zeit mehr als 1,6
millionen mal abgerufen in dem video
schildert sie einen krassen fall von
diskriminierung sie hat sich bei edeka
beworben und den job nicht erhalten weil
sie ein kopftuch trägt über die reaktion
auf ihr video haben wir mit ihr
gesprochen
ja ich selber arbeit gedacht dass es so
die leute in meinem umfeld mitbekommen
und dann wurde es aber überall gepostet
geteilt und ja also ich würde die tag
auch auf die straße erkannt und also
bist du das nicht das mädchen aus dem
video und ich sage also ich das video
ich bin generell eine person ich mache
oft mein mund auf wenn ich so sehr da
erst in der ungerechtigkeit deswegen ja
glaub ich muss ich noch mal wieder der
filialleiter von dem du sozusagen
abgelehnt wurde hat sich im nachhinein
jetzt bei dir entschuldigt und der
konzern edeka hat er außerdem angeboten
dass du einen job bei einer materie
haben kannst nicht sein dass du diese
reaktion nimmst du die entschuldigung an
also bei mir persönlich hat sich der
filialleiter nicht entschuldigt also bei
mir es wieder eine mail noch irgendwie
da nachricht angekommen ich hab es dann
irgendwann in den medien gelesen dass er
sich entschuldigt hat er hat glaube ich
irgend einem posting von dir da
kommentiert das casa ich habe es nicht
gelesen deswegen kann es natürlich sein
ich selber bin noch keine nachtragende
person oder so also ich einem menschen
leben vom principal einmal an ich meine
wir sind menschen wir machen alle fehler
es war nur es hat sich eben nicht so
echt angeführt sondern eher sowie
schadensbegrenzung dass man jetzt sieht
medien video gepostet 1,6 millionen
leute haben das gesehen ich sollte mich
da auch irgendwie äußern
du warst gab dabei zu erzählen dass du
dir generell etwas von edeka wünschen
würde ist dass sie sich öffentlich noch
mal gas
distanzieren von ihm weil sie ja selber
auch gesagt haben dass sie für vielfalt
stehen dass sie sowas nicht unterstützen
dass ich einfach noch mal vielleicht
auch maßnahmen ergreifen dass so was in
dem real nicht passieren kann um damit
diskriminierung jeglicher art eben ja
unterbindet wird sage ich jetzt mal also
nicht nur durch trägerin sondern
generell herkunft religion sexualität
also dass man generell maßnahmen
ergreift ja unterstützt wird die
16-jährige von youtube ihren berliner
sophie also ich finde schon dass wenn
man gerade wenn man so diskriminiert
wird weil es ist ja wirklich wie kann
man aufgrund vom tragen eines kopftuches
abgelehnt werden das ist also ich finde
es super dass sie diese reichweite oder
nur zwei darauf muss auf jeden fall
aufmerksam gemacht werden ich sehe das
ganz genauso und ich finde das gut wenn
darüber gesprochen wird ich bin das
nicht so gut wenn leute dann tatsächlich
einfach vielleicht auch ein bisschen
abgeschreckt sind dadurch und sich nicht
zu wort melden sich wieder schon gut
wenn man seine plattform nutzt und
darauf aufmerksam macht gerade damit die
leute mal wissen was dieser welt so
abgeht wenn so jemand seine plattform
nicht nutzt dann erfährt man davon nicht
[Musik]